I'm you got engaged that's what I wanted
to tell I want this valley airy there's
a story yeah I have heard this story
before
you know I'm not gonna you know show for
you and just be like I understood you
know what I mean I know there's a story
I'd like you to tell that story oh you
know it because you're directly involved
with ruining my engagement you're
directly involved with ruining the
surprise of my you know you proposed to
someone you love you'd like it to be a
surprise right well then don't involve
feet home so basically you know buying a
ring took a lot longer than I thought it
was multiple days of looking at
different engagement rings for my fiance
yeah I don't like that word I say former
girlfriend so I had to keep coming up
with excuses for leaving the house and
at this time I was gainfully unemployed
so it was difficult we're not one of
those couples where I can be like I just
need to drive and she's like I get it'd
be you know I have to come up with full
lines right no we're out we're out of
pineapple yeah as you're heaving
pineapple find out window we're out of
high-level so I had to come up with
reasons to leave the house and I figured
like I'm gonna say I'm having lunch with
a friend and I decided to say Pete
Holmes you were all you also had a lot
of free time at this time and I knew
that if I said I was having lunch with
Pete Holmes my girlfriend would not want
to come
not she loves she loves having lunch
with any comedian we're just gonna do
bits the whole time yeah sure sure sure
I was like who will do the most bits in
the world
oh he find out like hey I'm gonna go
hang out with Buddy Hackett do you want
to cut right now I'm like a modern day
woman I'm not gonna do that so I text
you now I'm a 21st century individual
and I knew that people now post on
Twitter whatever hey I'm at the Grove
hey I'm at the Grove you know I am a Leo
and I said Pete I'm using you as my
alibi to buy an engagement ring
please don't tweet like hey weirdos I'm
in Austin or anything like where you
would reveal that you're not at lunch
with me Pete writes back immediately got
won't won't tweet anything like that I
go out I buy an engagement ring I
surprised surprised my girlfriend she
thinks we're flying back to New York we
drive to a beach in Malibu I propose is
very beautiful afterwards we're driving
back and I say you know were you really
surprised and she said no she's like
that day you said you were with Pete
Holmes you weren't and I said how did
you know that and she said cuz he
instagrammed a photo of himself
recording a podcast while I was supposed
to be at lunch with you now in fairness
to Pete I said don't tweet anything
ah we have a photo I think I we have the
photo that you Instagram that ruined
mine
dumb Golden Retriever that's you with
progressive pastor Rob Bell yes you got
a post that and and and Anna said and I
knew he couldn't have done lunch and a
podcast cuz his podcast last for three
hours
hi I'm very excited you play a part in
it you know my weird narcissism was ill
I'm like I'm glad I'm cemented in the
story no yeah I was like what do I have
anecdotes now you do